you're starting in two minutes get the
meatballs ready sauce and meatballs the
kitchen classroom practice sessions with
a former chef the students here have a
secondary school education and this is
where they experienced the practical
side of their future profession are the
potato croquettes getting some color not
really enough yet but the guests will
arrive any minute the future cooks have
a lot left to do tonight they also have
concrete plans for the future I want to
take over the family business I'd like
to work in a hotel I've always wanted to
if you have a desire to learn you can
learn it all here but first they have to
get the food on the table students
teachers even the director all eat at
the school canteen it provides a daily
opportunity to practice and not just
balancing plates it's also about
interacting with guests can I get you
some water or one of our coffee
specialties almost 2,000 students from
more than 30 countries are learning a
profession here the Elizabeth is Elbert
School in the German town of Harman is
one of the best in the country it
received a prestigious prize this year
one reason for its success systemic
quality tests we look at the numbers in
terms of who graduated how happy they
were with their experience how satisfied
the teachers are and with these results
we've collected we can see which
projects and goals we want to have we
implement those plans and then we
evaluate them over a couple of years to
see if we achieve the goals or not if
the plans have had the desired effect
they go into the lineup but I've been
schooltas down houses and Hammond gets
you to become part of the lineup means
to be taken up in the school system like
independent work
the students are given specific tasks
and deadlines but we're in the school
building they perform them and whether
alone or in a group is up to them
the teachers are mentors and counselors
there are grades and reports of course
but for teachers as well as students
just as the teachers evaluate us we
evaluate them for example in terms of
how they structure the lessons and you
get the chance to offer suggestions like
I noticed how often she says
erm and maybe made her aware of it
basically it's the same thing teachers
do when they judge our presentations
some concepts Lloyd's wouldn't deal it
about one's life a lot of about the
teachers say they're grateful for the
feedback and that it actually makes
their work easier if I have a problem
with a class because for example I come
too late for a lesson or the grading
system is unclear or it's not clear what
the lesson is about then there's a
problem with the relationship then you
can try to teach them all day long but
it won't work they won't absorb anything
learning environment and practical
exercises are key especially when it
comes to professions that demand a lot
of interaction specialist knowledge is
just one aspect of the training equally
important is putting yourself in someone
else's shoes back to the gastronomy
students it's the end of the day
feedback time on a scale of 1 to 10 how
do they rate their own performance give
myself a 9 because I did what I was
supposed to do and helped out a lot I'd
give myself 7 points because I was a
little too loud but aside from that I
did ask if anyone needed help and so on
time to clean the kitchen and have a
laugh at the end of the day
the school is perfect it's certainly a
lot of fun here that's just the way a
school should be then enjoy your evening